[Musique]
bonjour à toutes et à tous vous regardez
l'échiquier mondial sur rt france au
sommaire aujourd'hui la guinée-bissau
deux mois après le scrutin présidentiel
ce pays s'enfonce dans une nouvelle
crise politique suscitée par un
contentieux électoral et cela malgré les
efforts de médiation de la communauté
internationale ce petit pays de l'ouest
de l'afrique dont la capitale se
prénomme également bissao et parfois
confondu à tort avec sa voisine la
guinée qui est dirigé par le président
alpha condé
alors quels sont les changements qui
secoue la vie politique bissau-guinéenne
ces derniers temps le 27 février dernier
umar aussi ce courant balou est investi
à bissau comme président de la
république pourtant la cérémonie
d'investiture est ternie par l'absence
de quasiment tous les hauts responsables
de l'état ni le premier ministre sortant
ni le président de l'assemblée nationale
ni même celui de la cour suprême ne sont
venus féliciter embalo car ils ne
reconnaissent pas sa victoire de son
côté le rival principal dans le balo à
cette élection domingos simoes pereira
se bat avec acharnement pour prouver la
fraude
il demande à la cour suprême du pays à
trois reprises de recompter les voix
seul problème cette procédure est formel
les procès verbaux sont recompter n'est
pas les bulletins de vote
entre-temps oumar aussi ce combat l'eau
en dos rapidement le rôle du chef de
l'état en moins de deux mois
il sera en visite officielle au sénégal
au nigeria au kenya au tchad et même
otto beau mais son plus proche voisin
la guinée non l'italienne ne fait pas
partie de son itinéraire
le président du pays alpha condé
refuserait selon la presse de
reconnaître la victoire dans balo et
appellerait la cedeao à faire de même
[Musique]
mais avant de poursuivre voici ce qu'il
faut savoir sur le vainqueur déclaré des
élections présidentielle en
guinée-bissau
c'est le blitz général de brigade plus
tard formé en relations internationales
oumarou au sissoko embalo occupe
plusieurs postes dans les précédents
gouvernements avant d'être nommé premier
ministre en 2016 ce pendant son mandat
et tumultueux d'abord c'est son propre
parti le parti africain pour
l'indépendance de la guinée et du cap
vert ou pas figé c'est qu'ils refusent
de soutenir son administration
plus tard il a entre en désaccord avec
le président du pis et démissionne
finalement en 2018
la même année il fait partie des quinze
députés qui tourne le dos aux pays
j'essaie et créer leurs propres forces
politiques le mouvement pour
l'alternative démocratique ou madm g15
l'année dernière ce parti est arrivé en
deuxième position aux élections
législatives décrochant 27 sièges sur
son dos au total al'approche des
présidentielles madm avance la
candidature dans ballot pour les
élections celui ci promet une lutte
impitoyable contre la corruption et le
trafic de drogue
arrivé deuxième au premier tour il
réussit néanmoins à rassembler les
soutien des principaux candidats
éliminés dont le président sortant josé
mario vaz ainsi il arrive à dépasser son
adversaire principal domingos simoes
pereira deux mois après les élections
présidentielles la guinée-bissau se
retrouve en proie à une profonde crise
politique
en cause les résultats du scrutin
annoncés par la commission électorale et
qui donnent vainqueur oumarou sissoko
embalo le candidat d'opposition pourtant
domingos simoes pereira le candidat du
parti au pouvoir refuse de reconnaître
sa défaite
le président de l'assemblée nationale et
le premier ministre du pays a eu aussi
estiment que ces élections sont pas
tâcher de fraude
la cour suprême ne se pressent pas non
plus de valider les résultats
et ce après 4 vérification dont une sous
l'égide de la cedeao
alors que le litige est toujours en
cours le président élu du pays entame
d'ores et déjà une série de visites à
l'étranger
le sénégal le nigeria le tchad le kenya
et même le togo
l'agenda est chargé oumar aussi ce qu en
ballots se cherche de nouvelles amitiés
et veut renforcer la coopération
avec ses voisins cependant à croire
certaines sources le président de la
guinée conakry serait plutôt sceptique
vis-à-vis de la victoire dans le balo et
refuserait pour l'instant de reconnaître
sa victoire
alors quels défis se dressent devant le
nouveau président bissao guinéen at il
des chances de gagner son ultime
bataille celle du recomptage des voix
et comment la communauté internationale
réagit tel au chaos électoral qui règne
en guinée-bissau pour répondre à ces
questions nous rejoignons jean claude
félix tchicaya chercheur à l'institut de
prospective et sécurité en europe
monsieur félix tchicaya bonjour bonjour
tout d'abord lors du premier tour de la
présidentielle domingos simoes pereira
obtenu plus de 40% de voix contre
seulement auprès de 28 d'oumarou sissoko
embalo pourtant ce dernier réussit à
gagner lors du deuxième tour grâce à
quoi selon vous grâce à quelques
associations et quelques alliances
judicieuse et pertinente c'est vrai
qu'il a été sous-estimée par les
sondages et les analyses
il arrive un petit peu comme une
surprise au 2e tour le parti historique
semblait parti pour gagner encore une
fois les élections de manière aisée et
facile il n'en a rien été et au second
tour les alliances qui ont été faites
par monsieur oumarou se se sont trouvés
donc
judicieuse et voirol fructueuse parce
qu'il est passé devant avec plus de 53%
des voix
pourtant pereira ne rendent pas les
armes et conteste les résultats devant
la cour suprême en dénonçant la fraude
électorale
pensez vous il peut avoir au moins
partiellement raison partiellement
raison je ne sais pas en tout cas il a
tout un dossier qui lui permet de poser
recours comme la loi glycéro ghislaine
le permet donc la cour suprême est en
train depuis quand même des longues
semaines maintenant ce qui représente
quand même quelques difficultés sur
l'apaisement du climat social depuis
deux mois en guinée-bissau qui attend
donc qui attend donc les résultats avec
une impatience mais aussi quelques peur
parce que c'est un c'est un pays qui a
habitué aux coups d'état qui habitué aux
coups de force qui habitués et de
violence politique chronique
et pourtant la géopolitique du peuple
guinéen comme l'ensemble du continent
africain veulent du changement il
voulait aussi une réforme des attitudes
et comportements des visions du parti
majoritaire à l'assemblée nationale qui
pose recours il a sûrement des éléments
dans son dossier de recours qui lui
permet donc de poser recours et les deux
camps attendent plus la société civile
la réponse de la cour suprême qui
j'espère va donner sa réponse le plus
vite possible selon vous qui a le plus
de chances de prendre le dessus dans
cette bataille en ballet opéra qui est
aussi soutenu par le parlement
d'ailleurs il soutenu par le parlement
la commission technique en tout cas
nationale des sur le plan électoral lui
le considère comme président élu au
regard des suffrages qu'elle a
additionné conjuguer analysés dont il
est le président élu n'est pas encore le
président endroit parce qu'ils manquent
donc la décision de la cour suprême
c'est pour cela que il est rentré dans
cette brèche
si je puis dire sur le plan juridique où
il s'est installé au palais présidentiel
en nommant un premier ministre qui nomme
un nouveau gouvernement
mais comment nommer un nouveau
gouvernement avec une un parlement qui
est majoritairement en tout cas celui
porté par le parti qui le parti sortant
donc le parti psg le parti historique de
la guinée-bissau
donc là on voit que ce dilemme politique
que ressemble malheureusement comme deux
gouttes d'eau à tout à toutes les
chroniques
si j'allais dire politique de la
guinée-bissau merci beaucoup monsieur
félix tchicaya nous allons poursuivre
notre analyse tout de suite mais nous
retrouverons en fin d'émission pour plus
de détails sur la question merci le 27
février 2020 le président-élu bissao
guinéen oumaro sissoko embalo entre
officiellement en fonctions après avoir
prêté serment dans un hôtel de luxe à
bissao le nouveau chef de l'état se
dirigent vers le palais présidentiel
pour la cérémonie de passation du
pouvoir
candidat de l'opposition au maroussi ce
quoi en ballots et proclamé vainqueur de
l'élection présidentielle le 1er janvier
de mes vingt une annonce qui résonne
comme un coup de tonnerre pour l'élite
politique bissau-guinéenne
car en ballots n'était pas du tout le
favori de la course présidentielle au
premier tour qui s'est déroulé fin
novembre 2019
il arrive en deuxième position avec
seulement 27 65% des voix devant lui
domingos simoes pereira chef du parti
historique au pouvoir le psg sait y
recueille plus de 40% des soutiens
cependant le rapport de force change
radicalement
lors de la campagne de
l'entre-deux-tours emballe ossature tout
d'abord du soutien des principaux
candidats éliminés dont le président
sortant josé mario vaz et peut désormais
compter sur la majeure partie de son
électorat par ailleurs en ballots mail
sa campagne sur des thèmes sensibles
comme la lutte contre la pauvreté le
redressement urgent de l'économie
bissau-guinéenne suivi de près à
l'international les élections sont
reconnus comme transparente et crédible
par l'onu
le représentant spécial du secrétaire
général applaudi le peuple de
guinée-bissau pour le bon déroulement
des élections et l'atmosphère pacifique
qui a prévalu tout au long du processus
électoral
cette opinion n'est pourtant pas partagé
par l'adversaire principal dans ballot
domingos simoes pereira qui refuse de
croire à la légitimité des résultats les
résultats provisoires qui viennent
d'être proclamés sont plaints
d'irrégularités de nullité et de
manipulation de fraude électorale
un tel résultat nous ne pouvons pas
l'accepter nous allons amener toutes les
preuves qui démontrent que les résultats
ont été modifiées par conséquent pereira
dépose une plainte dénonçant la fraude
électorale devant la cour suprême
un acte qui déclenche en long feuilleton
électoral toujours en cours aujourd'hui
en guinée-bissau et l'exigence de
pereira et d'annuler les résultats du
second tour cependant la cour suprême
décide de procéder non pas à
l'annulation mais au recomptage des
procès-verbaux du second tour
il ne s'agit pourtant pas des bulletins
de vote comme le conte pereira tente de
le présenter la cedeao soutient cette
demande exige une vérification des
procès verbaux sous son égide
à la suite de l'opération la victoire
dans balou est confirmée le 4 février
pereira insiste pourtant pour faire
annuler les résultats une nouvelle
plainte et dons déposés en réponse la
cour suprême ordonne une nouvelle fois
le recomptage des procès-verbaux
toujours pas et bulletins résultat la
victoire dans balo et reconfirmé une
fois de plus mais pereira ne compte pas
reculer le 26 février il saisit une
nouvelle fois la cour suprême cette fois
il justifie sa demande par un rapport
d'audit des procès verbaux rédigés par
un cabinet privé
il a lui même mandaté selon le document
des irrégularités auraient été
enregistrées dans la moitié de tous les
districts dans ce bras de fer juridique
pereira un soutien de taille c'est son
propre parti paillis gc qui
conjointement avec ses alliés contrôlent
aujourd'hui la majorité des sièges au
parlement bissao guinéen en parlement
qui refuse de reconnaître
embalo comme président en tant que le
contentieux électoral n'est pas résolue
tant que la cour suprême n'aura pas
rendu son jugement il est attesté de
façon incontestable qu'il ne peut y
avoir un président élu
à la suite du scrutin du 29 décembre le
premier ministre sortant lui va encore
plus loin en qualifiant l'investiture du
président du coup d'état l'investiture
dans balou est un coup d'état et
constitue un affront la cour suprême de
justice et au parlement le 28 février le
premier ministre sortant est limogé par
le président élu
c'est le premier décret bamba l'eau
après son investiture le nouveau chef du
gouvernement sera nuno gomes nabias un
des candidats du premier tour qui a
soutenu un ballo lors du second
parallèlement le pays fait face au
risque d'une confrontation des pouvoirs
législatif et exécutif
les députés fidèles au paillage et cdi
le président de l'assemblée nationale
cipriano cassama comme président
intérimaire pourtant ce dernier choisit
de démissionner moins de deux jours
après sa désignation une décision qu'il
explique par des menaces de mort à
l'égard de lui-même et de sa famille
cette situation résulte largement de
l'instabilité politique qui secoue le
pays ces dernières décennies
quels en sont les origines comme embalo
compte-t-il faire évoluer la politique
du pays à l'international et où le camp
de pereira cherche-t-il ses soutiens la
réponse après la pause
[Musique]
plus de deux mois après les élections
présidentielles la guinée-bissau fait
face à une profonde crise postélectorale
cette instabilité politique n'est
pourtant pas un phénomène nouveau dans
ce pays africain qui a connu très peu de
moments calmes dans son histoire colonie
portugaise la guinée bissao obtient son
indépendance en 1974 à la suite d'une
longue guerre de libération menée par le
parti africain pour l'indépendance de la
guinée et du cap vert ou pgc la même
année c'est l'un de ses chefs de file
luis cabral qui prend la tête du pays
dès lors il met en place une politique
socialiste autoritaire il nationalise
les terres et met en place une nouvelle
monnaie le peso pourtant cabral peine à
sortir le pays du gouffre économique et
de la famille laissant place à une
grogne sociale grandissante le 14
novembre 1980 cabral est renversé par un
coup d'état militaire
l'année suivante un gouvernement
provisoire appelée conseil de la
révolution est mise en place
il est présidé par le premier ministre
joao vieira à la tête du pays
vieira entreprend de nombreuses réformes
il fait adopter une nouvelle
constitution en 1984 qui est à bien
pouvoir présidentiel avec le paillage et
c'est comme parti unique
pourtant dès 1986 vieira commence à
libéraliser l'économie
en 1989 il modifier à nouveau la
constitution et réintroduit le
multipartisme le 15 juin de la même
année le paillage et c'est remporté les
élections législatives avec près de 96%
des voix
quatre jours plus tard joao vieira est
reconduit à la tête du pays lors des
premières élections présidentielles
pluralistes en 1994
vieira redevient nouveau président avec
près de 52 % des voix
pourtant 1998 une guerre civile éclate
elle intervient suite au limogeage du
général ansumane mané accusé par le
président vieira de soutenir les
indépendantistes casamançais au sénégal
un soulèvement militaire est alors menée
par manet contre les fidèles de vieira
ce conflit dure près d'un an est en
train de la mort de plusieurs milliers
de personnes
les rebelles renverse finalement le
gouvernement de joao vieira le 7 mai
ce dernier est poussé à l'exil et trouve
refuge au portugal lors des élections
présidentielles de 2000 c'est une balle
à la leader de l'opposition qui est élu
président il hérite d'un pays très
affaibli économiquement par la guerre
civile en 2003 après seulement trois
années à la tête du pays là là lui aussi
est renversé par les militaires lors
d'un nouveau coup d'état
il est accusé de favoriser sa communauté
ethnique balante et et d'euros poussés à
maintes reprise la tenue d'élections
législatives
c'est henrique rosa qui le remplace
comme président par intérim
retournez en guinée-bissau après six ans
d'exil e joao vieira est réélu président
lors des élections de 2005
ils s'engagent à poursuivre le
développement économique et la
réconciliation nationale
vieira veut avant tout faire table rase
du passé il fait adopter en 2007 une loi
qui amnistie les auteurs de coups d'état
et d'assassinats politiques entre 1980
et 2004
en dépit de cette politique d'apaisement
joao vieira sera assassiné par la junte
militaire en mars 2009 au cours d'un
attentat meurtrier dès lors des
élections anticipées ont lieu en juin
c'est malam bacaï sahna candidat du pdc
qui élu président en souhaitant mettre
fin au trafic de drogue et la corruption
grandissante son élection est perçu par
le peuple comme un signe d'espoir pour
le pays
cependant ça l'un décède au cours de son
mandat en janvier 2012 le 12 avril de la
même année un coup d'état militaire a
lieu entre les deux tours de l'élection
destinée à désigner le successeur de
sanaa afin de retrouver une stabilité
politique un accord de transition est
conclu entre la gente militaire et les
partis politiques le 18 avril 2012
il prévoit la création d'un conseil
national de transition afin d'organiser
les élections présidentielle et
législatives dans un délai maximal de
deux ans en 2014
josé mario vaz est enfin élu président
de guinée-bissau
alors que son élection donne un certain
espoirs d'accalmie et instabilité
politique persiste en effet entre 2014
et 2016 plusieurs premiers ministres
vont se succéder en raison de désaccords
avec basse afin de sortir de l'impasse
le président guinéen alpha condé et son
homologue de sierra leone ernest baï
koroma se pose en 2016 comme médiateur
de la crise bissau guinéenne la même
année les accros de conakry sont signés
par les membres du gouvernement guinéen
il porte sur la mise en place de
réformes constitutionnelles électorale
le tout visant à rétablir un équilibre
politique dans le pays
pourtant les accords de conakry ne sont
pas tout à fait respecté en effet entre
2016 et 2018 les premiers ministres
continuent de se succéder les élections
présidentielles quant à elles ont lieu
fin 2019
et c'est finalement oumaro sissoko en
ballot que nous avons évoquées qui est
élu président de guinée-bissau dans les
rues du pays c'est pour l'instant le
calme relatif la bataille se joue sur le
plan juridique pourtant la perspective
d'une nouvelle crise institutionnelle et
le chaos qu'elle pourrait entraîner
inquiète déjà à l'onu étant donnée la
profonde méfiance entre les deux camps
politiques
les divisions au sein de l'exécutif et
les alliances politiques changeantes au
sein du parlement
la prestation de serment du futur
président ne permettra probablement pas
d'apporter la stabilité afin d'éviter
l'escaladé les violences la communauté
internationale exhorte donc ses
partenaires africains à apporter leur
soutien à la guinée-bissau le temps que
la situation se stabilise le conseil
exécutif a appelé tous les partenaires à
continuer de soutenir la guinée-bissau à
ce stade critique alors que le pays
redouble d'efforts pour assurer la
stabilité le développement
ainsi que pour mettre fin au fléau du
trafic de drogue et promouvoir la
gouvernance démocratique et l'état de
droit
pourtant dans le voisinage immédiat de
la guinée-bissau ce soutien ressemble
plutôt à des pressions la cedeao qui a
été déjà intervenue dans le pays pendant
la crise précédente de 2016 suit de très
près la situation tout en appelant les
acteurs politiques et les institutions à
coopérer pour la résolution de la crise
elle n'hésite pas à hausser le ton des
sanctions pourront être prises contre
tous les acteurs qu'ils n'agiraient pas
dans le sens de la normalisation
politique et institutionnelle depuis le
début de la crise la cedeao s'accordent
le rôle central dans sa résolution
mais ce rôle est un bégu le 22 janvier
2020 et félicite sissoko en ballot pour
sa victoire et rétropédale une semaine
plus tard en envoyant une commission
dans le pays dans un communiqué publié
ensuite et les vides de prendre parti et
appelle à la coopération
le 9 février la cedeao se réunit en
sommet extraordinaire en marge de la
session de l'union africaine à addis
abeba la séance débouche sur une
exigence ferme la justice bissau
guinéenne doit régler le contentieux
électoral avant le 15 février une
demande mal vécu à bissao même si la
cour suprême est toujours engagé dans le
bras de fer avec la commission
électorale du pays elle refuse
l'ingérence dans ses affaires et
rejettent une éventuelle médiation
en attendant le président élu lui agi
d'ores et déjà en tant que tel
sans attendre les conclusions de la plus
haute juridiction de son pays oumarou
aussi ce qu en ballots cherche les
faveurs des voisins afin de consolider
sa position à l'international
pour ce faire deux jours après l annonce
de sa victoire le président élu entame
une série de visites à l'étranger selon
les médias locaux il s'agirait de
remercier ses homologues pour leur
soutien parmi eux le sénégalais macky
sall en tout premier au maroussi sakho
embalo parle comme d'un frère de celui
qui l'a soutenu dans des moments
difficiles
viennent ensuite congo brazzaville
nigeria tchad kenya et même le togo
partout l'amitié mutuelles et le
renforcement de la coopération sont au
centre de l'agenda
cependant la grande absente de cette
tournée africaine et la guinée conakry
pourquoi entre le président guinéen
alpha condé ou marot sissoko en ballots
l'hostilité ne date pas d'hier en
février 2010 est fraîchement nommé
premier ministre
ce dernier s'est déjà attaqué aux chefs
d'état de la guinée conakry alors
médiateur international de la crise
bissau guinéenne selon embalo alpha
condé lui aurait mis des bâtons dans les
roues en bloquant son programme au
parlement
je ne peux pas avoir de la haine envers
lui juste parce qu'il ne m'aimait pas il
a tout fait pour que je ne sois pas
président mais dès lors que les
bissau-guinéens monté lui les attaques
entre lui et moi c'est fini
le président élu est fidèle à sa parole
dès sa victoire concrétiser il abandonne
les attaques contre alpha condé et
relativise c'était simplement des mots
de campagne électorale cependant et at
il des faits concrets qui puisse
justifier l'indignation d'oumarou
sissoko en ballots en effet lors de la
séance de la cedeao le 9 février alpha
condé aurait effectivement plaidé en
soutien de revendications de domingos
simoes pereira
selon le journal du cameroun il aurait
appelé à ne pas reconnaître la victoire
dans ballot proclamés par la commission
nationale électorale
un argument qui aurait été déterminant
pour la position de la cedeao pour sa
part et selon le média sénégalais
dakaractu après une énième confirmation
de la victoire bamba l'eau le paillis gc
aurait appelé ses soutiens étrangers à
l'aide selon une lettre datée du 18
février il s'adresse au président
guinéen ghanéen est ivoirien
les trois pays curieusement absent de
l'itinéraire de la tournée africaine
dans ballot tant que la crise électorale
perdure les influences étrangères jours
ont elles un rôle dans sa résolution la
cedeao passera-t-elle des paroles à des
actions concrètes pour sortir de cette
impasse
pour mieux comprendre quelles forces
sont en action en guinée-bissau
nous revenons vers jean claude félix
tchicaya chercheur à l'institut de
prospective et sécurité en europe
monsieur tchikaya selon oumarou sissoko
embalo alpha condé a tout fait pour
qu'il ne soit pas président est ce vrai
pensez vous et y at il d'autres voisins
de la guinée-bissau qui ne voulait
peut-être pas l'arrivée dans ballot au
pouvoir là il ya plusieurs plusieurs
voix il ya celle de monsieur ben arous
simaro qui dit que monsieur alpha condé
aurait eu donc
un côté partisan dans les négociations
notamment de 2016
et d'après il n'aurait pas joué son rôle
de médiation et monsieur alpha condé lui
aujourd'hui est confronté dans une crise
politique avec à l'intérieur de son
changement de constitution à cheval de
troie qui va lui permettre de se
représenter pour un troisième mandat ce
qui soulève l'ire de l'opposition et de
la plus grande partie de sa société
guinéenne de conakry sur les paroles de
monsieur oumarou je pense que là nous
sommes dans dans la géopolitique est
certain c'est vrai en tant que président
avait plus de 2 de préférence entre
guillemets sur le plan politique
géopolitique pour la partie sortante du
pouvoir et d'autres comme le sénégal
comme le tchad comme le nigeria qui ont
soutenu sans dire qu'ils étaient
partisans mais ils soutiennent le prédit
le président dix élus en tout cas par la
commission électorale de la
guinée-bissau
donc on voit bien d'ailleurs la tournée
de monsieur oumarou sissoko allant dans
les pays frontaliers mais pas seulement
chercher des adoubement d'ailleurs qui
peuvent poser question parce qu'il parle
de démocratie et autres il est allé voir
quand même des états des présidents
assez sulfureux qui ne sont pas connus
pour une une 1h gestion démocratique
c'est le moins qu'on puisse dire de leur
propre pays
ce qui pose d'ex qui posent des
questions mais surtout qui met en
difficulté notamment l'union africaine
et la cedeao qui à l'intérieur de ses
membres qui parfois nomme comme
médiateur ce sont des médiateurs qui
sont souvent non démocratiques dans leur
propre pays qui souvent triture la
constitution pour s'imposer et rester au
pouvoir
donc voilà il ya tout le dilemme il ya
une géopolitique des peuples en afrique
et dans le monde et je vais rester en
afrique qui veut qu'ils veulent et la
géopolitique géopolitique des peuples
veut vraiment qu'il ya un changement
mais malheureusement au sein même des
médiations étatique
elles ne sont pas toujours légitimes et
légitimé par leur bilan démocratique qui
est pour le moins famélique
hier la cedeao menace de sanctions
contre tous les acteurs qu'ils
n'agiraient pas dans le sens de la
normalisation politique sans pourtant
prendre parti dans cette crise pensez
vous que l'organisation doit prendre une
position peut-être plus ferme avant que
cela ne soit trop tard
oui il doit prendre une une décision une
décision ferme
elle est un petit peu en retard
d'ailleurs ç'a permis à des adil a
permis à d'autres organisations
internationales
en dehors du continent de prendre des
positions fermes aussi mais cela
revenait de manière spécifique aussi
prioritaire à la cedeao et à l'union
africaine qui est dans le flou qui ne se
positionne pas vraiment la cedeao
on attend est là hier elle a été assez
ferme et claire elle ne reconnaît aucune
des institutions aucune des décisions
politiques qui se sont installés sans
l'aval de la cour suprême donc sont sans
l'aval de la cour suprême qui est quand
même celle qui va désigner le président
endroit on s'achemine peut-être vers un
nouveau scrutin étant donné le dilemme
et on n'en sort pas depuis des semaines
donc on se dirige peut-être vers un
scrutin un scout à est-ce que cela va
susciter et soulever le peuple et qui
est ce que le peuple bissau guinéen à
herat dans la rue je ne crois pas parce
que le peuple bissao guinéen le peuple
âme est trop fatigué de ce que j'ai
annoncé tout à l'heure
comme les chroniques politiques ou
souvent exigeront la conscience et la
poitrine en avant et malheureusement il
ya des morts donc ils ont envie quand
même d'avoir une stratégie beaucoup plus
démocratique et attendent que la cour
suprême se prononce
merci beaucoup jean claude félix
tchicaya je rappelle vous êtes chercheur
à l'institut de prospective et sécurité
en europe merci d'avoir été là d'avoir
apporté votre éclairage aujourd'hui dans
cette émission
cette partie là n'est pas encore
terminée la semaine prochaine une
nouvelle partie vous attend avec
d'autres pions sur l'échiquier mondial
à bientôt sur rt france
[Musique]